[Music]
I'm just gonna do what I have to do
follow the rules and hopefully be you
know still a role model it's kind of
crazy that it's surreal to me so that
was one of the last times each he spoke
to Abby Lee Miller before she entered
federal prison
the former Dance Moms star was set for
an early release last week but she's now
playing a waiting game behind bars I
don't know what the future holds et has
learned Abby's delay has to do with the
ship in the Bureau of Prisons quote it's
not personal to Abby it's happening to
women in all different federal prisons
men too but more to women so here's how
it works
prisons reportedly have a budget to pay
for inmates to be released into halfway
houses
Abby received official paperwork to be
released from the federal correction
complex in Victorville California on
February 20th into a halfway house in
Van Nuys according to prison consultant
and coach Jennifer Myers quote the
prison went over-budget so she could no
longer be released 51 year old Abby is
now reportedly in the process of
receiving a new out date but et has
learned she was not pleased when she
didn't leave prison as planned quote it
was a pretty upsetting thing for her
over the weekend to not be able to talk
to anybody and find out what was
happening it didn't make any sense you
know what I need to think about
something else
[Music]